so let me thank you for the opportunity
to talk about the biggest international
story of your professional lifetime
which is also the most important
international challenge the world will
face for as far as the eye can see the
story of course is the rise of China
never before if so many people risen so
far so fast on so many different
dimensions the challenge is the impact
of China's rise the discombobulation
this will cause the United States and
the international order of which the US
has been the principal architect and
Guardian the past hundred years have
been what historians now call an
american century Americans have become
accustom to their place at the top of
every pecking order so the very idea of
another country that could be as big and
strong as the US or bigger strikes many
Americans as the salt on who they are
for perspective on what we're now seeing
in this rivalry it's useful to locate it
on the larger map of history the past
500 years have seen 16 cases in which a
rising power threatened to this place a
ruling power 12 of those ended in war
so just November we'll all pause to mark
the hundredth anniversary of the final
day of a war that became so encompassing
that required historians to create an
entirely new category world war so on
the 11th hour of the 11th day of the
11th month in 1918 the guns of World War
one fell silent but 20 million
individuals lay dead
I know that this is a sophisticated
audience so you know about the rise of
China I'm gonna focus therefore on the
impact of China's rise
on the US on the international order and
on the prospects for war and peace but
having taught at Harvard over many years
I've learned that from time to time it's
useful to take a short pause just to
make sure we're all on the same page so
the way I do this is I call a timeout
I give soon as a pop quiz ungraded of
course okay so let's try this
quit timeout pop quiz question 40 years
ago 1978 China sets out on its march to
the market at that point what percentage
of China's 1 billion citizens were
struggling to survive on less than $2 a
day
take a guess 25% 50 75 90 what do you
think ninety-nine out of every 10 on
less than $2 a day 2018 40 years later
what about the numbers what's your bet
take a look
fewer than one in a hundred today and
China's president has promised that
within the next two years
those last tens of millions will have
been raised up above that threshold so
it's a miracle actually in our lifetime
hard to believe but brute facts are even
harder to ignore a nation that didn't
even appear on in either international
league tables 25 years ago has soared
the rival and in some areas surpass the
United States thus the challenge that
will shape our world a seemingly
unstoppable rising China accelerating
towards an apparently immovable ruling
us on course for what could be the
grandest collision in history to help us
get our minds around this challenge I'm
going to introduce you to a great
thinker I'm going to present a big idea
and I'm going to pose a most
consequential question so the great
thinker is lucidity z-- now I know his
name is a mouthful and some people have
trouble pronouncing it so let's do it
one two three together through Citadis
one more time lucidity so who was lucid
ities he was the father and founder of
history he wrote the first ever history
book it's titled the history of the
Peloponnesian War about the war in in
Greece 2500 years ago so if nothing else
today you can tweet your friends I met a
great thinker and I can even pronounce
his name their infinities so about this
war between that destroyed classical
Greece lucidity --zz wrote famously it
was the rise of Athens and the fear that
this instilled in Sparta that made the
war inevitable so the rise of one the
reaction of the other create a toxic
cocktail of pride arrogance paranoia
that drugged the both to war which
brings me to the big idea through
Citadis trap lucidity strap is a term I
coined several years ago to make vivid
through Citadis insight lucidity strap
is the dangerous dynamic that occurs
when a rising power threatens to
displace a ruling power like Athens or
Germany a hundred years ago or China
today and their impact on Sparta or
Great Britain a hundred years ago or the
u.s. today
as skin read Kissinger is said once you
get this idea this concept of Thucydides
trap turn in your head
it'll provide a lens for helping you
look through the news and noise of the
day to understand what's actually going
on so to the most consequential question
about our world today are we going to
follow in the footsteps
history or can we through a combination
of imagination and common sense and
courage find a way for the this to
manage this rivalry without a war nobody
wants and everybody knows would be
catastrophic give me five minutes to
unpack this and that later this
afternoon when you the next news story
pops up for you about China doing this
or the u.s. reacting like that you'll be
able to have a better understanding of
what's going on and even to explain it
to your friends so as we saw with this
flipping the pyramid of poverty
China has actually soared this meteoric
former Czech president václav havel I
think put it best he said all this has
happened so fast we haven't yet had time
to be astonished to remind myself how
astonished I should be I occasioned you
look out the window in my office in
Cambridge at this bridge which goes
across the Charles River between the
Kennedy School and Harvard Business
School in 2012 state of Massachusetts
said they were going to renovate this
bridge it would take two years in 2014
they said it wasn't finished in 2015
they said it would take one more year in
2015 they said it's not finished we're
not going to tell you when it's gonna be
finished finally last year it was
finished three times over budget now
compare this to a similar bridge that I
drove across last month in Beijing it's
called the San Yan Bridge in 2015 the
Chinese decided they wanted to renovate
that bridge it actually has twice as
many lanes of traffic how long did it
take for them to complete the project
2015 what do you bet think I guess take
a look
the answer is 43 hours
now of course that couldn't happen in
New York yes behind his speed and
execution is a Purpose Driven leader and
a government that works the most
ambitious and most competent leader on
the international stage today is Chinese
President Xi Jinping and he's made no
secret about what he wants as he said
when he became president six years ago
his goal is to make China great again a
banner he raised long before Donald
Trump picked up a version of this too
that in Xi Jinping has announced
specific targets for specific dates 2025
2035 2040 nine by 2025 China means to be
the dominant power in the major market
in ten leading technologies including
driverless cars robots artificial
intelligence quantum computing by 2035
China means to be the innovation leader
across all the advanced technologies and
by 2049 which is the hundredth
anniversary of the founding of the
People's Republic China means to be
unambiguously number one including as
she simply an army that he cost quote
fight and win so these are audacious
goals but as you can see
China's already well on its way to these
objectives and we should remember how
fast our world is changing 30 years ago
the world wide web had not yet even been
in
who feel the impact of this rise of
China most directly obviously the
current number one as China gets bigger
and stronger and richer technologically
more advanced it'll inevitably bump up
against American positions and
prerogatives now for red-blooded
Americans and especially for red-necked
Americans like me I'm from North
Carolina
there's something wrong with this
picture the USA means number one that's
who we are but again to repeat brute
facts or hard to ignore four years ago
Senator John McCain asked me to testify
about this to his Senate Foreign
Relations or Senate Armed Services
Committee and so I made for them a chart
that you can see that said compare the
US and China the kids on opposite ends
of a seesaw on a playground each
represented by the size of their economy
as late as 2004 China was just half our
size by 2014 its gdp was equal to ours
and on the current trajectory by 2024
it'll be half again larger the
consequences of this tectonic change
will be felt everywhere for example in
the current trade conflict
China's already the number one trading
partner of all the may Asia all the
major Asian countries which brings us
back to our Greek historian Harvard
still Sinha t-strap case file has
reviewed the last 500 years of history
and found 16 cases in which a rising
power threatened to displace a ruling
power 12 of these ended in war and the
tragedy of this is that in very few of
these that either of the protagonists
won award few of these wars were
initiated by either the rising power or
the ruling power so how does this work
what happens is a third party's
provocation
forces one or the other to react and
that sets in motion a spiral which drags
the two somewhere they don't want to go
if that seems crazy it is but it's life
remember World War one the provocation
in that case was the assassination of a
several second level figure Archduke
Franz Ferdinand which then leads the
austro-hungarian Emperor to issue a
ultimatum to Serbia they dragged in the
very cell eyes within two months all of
Europe was at war
so imagine through Sidda T's were
watching planet Earth today what would
he say
could he find a more appropriate leading
man for the ruling power than Donald J
Trump or a more apt leap for the rising
power than G champagne and he would
scratch his head and certainly say he
couldn't think the more a man a more
colorful provocateur then North Korea's
Kim jong-un each seems determined to
play his assigned part and is right on
script so finally we conclude again with
the most consequential question the
question they'll have the gravest
consequences for the rest of our lives
or Americans in Chinese going to let the
forces of history drive us to a war that
would be catastrophic for both or can we
summon the imagination and courage to
find a way there survived together to
share the 20 liters if in the 21st
century or as he's in pain to create a
new form of great power relations that's
the issue I've been pursuing
passionately for the last two years I've
had the opportunity to talk and it'd be
to listen to leaders of all the relevant
governments Beijing Washington Seoul
Tokyo to thought leaders across the
spectrum of both the arts and business I
wish I had more to report the good news
is that
leaders are increasingly aware of this
to Siddhant again dynamic and the
dangers that it pose the bad news is
that nobody has a feasible plan for
escaping history as usual so it's clear
to me that we need some ideas outside
the box of conventional statecraft
indeed from another page or another
space which is what brings me to Ted
today and which brings me to a request
this audience includes many of the most
creative minds on the planet will get up
in the morning and think not only about
how to manage the world we have but how
to create worlds that should be so I'm
hopeful that is this sinks in and as you
reflect on it some of you are gonna have
some bold ideas actually some wild ideas
that when we find will make a difference
in this space and just to remind you if
you do this won't be the first time let
me remind you what happened right after
World War two a remarkable group of
Americans and Europeans and others not
just from government but from the world
of culture and business engaged in a
collective surge of imagination and what
they imagined and what they created was
a new international order the order
that's allowed you and me to live our
lives all of our lives without great
power war and with more prosperity than
was ever seen before on the planet so a
remarkable story interestingly every
pillar of this project that produces
results when first proposed was rejected
by the foreign policy establishment as
naive or unrealistic so my favorite is
the Marshall Plan after World War two
Americans felt exhausted they had
immobilized 10 million troops they were
focused on an urgent domestic agenda but
as people began to appreciate how
devastated Europe was and how aggressive
Soviet Communism was
Americans eventually decided to tax
themselves
a percent and a half of GDP every year
for four years
and send that money to Europe to help
reconstruct these countries including
Germany and Italy whose troops had just
been killing Americans amazing this also
created the United Nations amazing the
Universal Declaration of Human Rights
the World Bank NATO all of these
elements of an order for peace and
prosperity so in a word what we need to
do is do it again and I think now we
need a surge of imagination creativity
informed by history for as the his as a
philosopher
Santayana reminded us in the end only
those who refuse to study history are
condemned to repeat it
thank you
[Applause]